my name is Max Lucca vir I am one half
of max and Jason of current TV
well I think that the most obvious way
in which current is different from other
networks is that the the values that are
sort of written into our Constitution
are inherently you know born of this Web
2.0 time which we sort of have all come
into where we sort of accept like an
interactive medium as sort of standard
or as like CNN you know has I report an
MTV tried with MTV flux which is website
current TV is inherently a dual-screen
experience where users can participate
in a multitude of ways in our
programming and you know that can range
from creating a short form documentary
in its entirety to submit to the network
or you know you can leave web comments
and text comments webcam responses on
our website for inclusion into our show
or on-air in many other ways we sort of
launched with with the goal of seeing Al
Gore's mission of democratizing the most
powerful medium that exists and that
we've sort of you know we haven't gone a
day without trying to figure out a new
and more innovative way to do that
our favorite segments to talk about
on-air are the the viewer created
segments because well part of the reason
why we came on board was because we
submitted a film that we produced in
college and so it's always refreshing
for us to see the work of other young
filmmakers and not only that but
sometimes you get most of the time you
get a perspective that you just won't
see on traditional and traditional news
media it's not always journalism but the
perspectives are just you know just
unbelievable I mean what we feel very
honored to sit on the front line of this
sort of the highest value user-generated
content production pipeline that exists
today I mean YouTube obviously is bigger
and is more ubiquitous but you have a
lot of videos of like you know people's
cats jumping through hula hoops or you
know the next Chris Crocker or out there
you know it's not it's all entertaining
but the user-generated content that
you're going to see on current is just
the production value is just you know
impeccable most of the time and so we
love it we get to see stories like you
know the underground party scene in
Karachi Pakistan nose jobs in Iran
apparently Iran is like the nose job
capital of the world you know everything
from that to underground
drifting circles in Northern California
so it's just it's really compelling it's
great for us because you know we you
know like we get to see the what's on
the sort of we get to keep our finger on
the pulse of what's on the minds of
people our age you know these are in
short documentaries that come from focus
groups or boardrooms and large media
conglomerates you know they come from
people just like Jason and I so it's
great those are our favorite pieces
those and then the the in-house
journalism that that current produces on
our Vanguard show
I think that one of the reasons why the
Internet is amazing is because you
really can't have both and I don't see a
problem per se with you know enjoying
the occasional consumption of celebrity
websites and the like you know I think
ultimately you want to live a life of
balance I do think though that what a
journalist is is sort of that perception
is shifting and evolving at a rapid pace
now with social broadcasting sites like
Twitter news and information is
disseminated often from regular people
that haven't gone to graduate school for
journalism and I think that we're
starting to see that people are becoming
more engaged with conscious media and
we've seen Obama come into office and
we've definitely Jason and I have been
privy to an entire generation of
outspoken passionate people that really
you know see change in the world and
have created ultimately change in the
world with his election yeah so I think
that you know sites like Twitter and and
even Facebook like people were
definitely using using media for the
betterment of society while they have
their Firefox tab open to Perez Hilton
like that's another situation but I
wouldn't I wouldn't - it because you
know occasionally people want to know
what's up with the latest celebrity aunt
well I think the virtue of short form
programming is that it's well suited to
a generation where we're all sort of
media oversaturated we all have a DD to
one degree or another I think it's uh I
just think it's easier to consume you
know a broader range of media when it's
all sort of you know short form I mean
you know Twitter is super popular for
having Status Messages they can only be
a hundred and forty characters also I
think that in terms of production
because I'm also a filmmaker I went to
school for film it's the immediacy of
getting to create a short form
documentary is great because I mean it
requires so much less time to tell a
story then the production that would go
into a feature-length documentary I
don't want to discredit feature-length
documentaries I think that some stories
you know when a story is good you can
you know there is no time limit um as
we've seen with you know Inconvenient
Truth and you know sicko was a man I
loved Michael Moore's documentaries I
don't know if I agree with everything he
says but I think that he obviously has a
knack for creating future length
documentaries that are compelling the
whole way through but in terms of like
daily consumption I just think that
there's an immediacy to the short form
pod that doesn't that didn't exist
before before before bite-sized
information was really as ubiquitous as
it is today
well I know that it's a struggle that
that we've faced before for example we
have we have a segment on current where
one of our journalists infiltrated the
sort of skinhead sect in Russia there's
a large population I guess of neo-nazis
in Russia and you know that's a story
that needs to be told and nobody else
has really told it the way that we did
but you you know you always want to be
careful to not perpetuate their hate you
don't want to give them a voice you want
to tell people what's going on without
sort of giving them a soapbox to stand
on so to speak so that is definitely a
you know a tricky situation but you know
that's that's always been a tricky
situation you know for any for any
journalist I think that just with the
the sort of the ability for with the
range of stories that are now being told
and sort of with the the information you
know overflow that is that all of our
fingertips I just think that people are
going to their sensors are going to be
more in tune to detect what is
what's not what is sort of you know
something worth reading up on what's not
and I just think the more information
the better the more the more information
we have available to us the more
fine-tuned our filtering our internal
filtering devices will get you know you
know it's it's not a one-way broadcast
anymore it's sort of a communication
with with with the powers that be with
with media in general and um you know
with that will become a greater a
greater sort of median of where the
truth lies
well when we first launched one of the
first stories that that I covered with
Jason was certainly crazy for me because
I had graduated from college like six
months ago you know prior to that point
was um going to purchase a fake social
security card with Jason and MacArthur
Park obviously Jason speaks Spanish so
he was more you know able to go in and
really you know speak the language and
and you know get the job done whereas I
stuck out like a sore thumb I was
wearing like board shorts at the time
and sunglasses like I just in the
context of the segment I looked
ridiculous but at the same time it was
you know it was pretty interesting for
the two of us to really you know get to
see that world and so Jason you know
bought himself a fake social security
card which a lot of undocumented workers
in Los Angeles need to do in order to
you know at least you know on paper be
able to say that they can legally work
for whatever it is a car wash so that
was definitely crazy I mean I was sort
of Jason was actually in the room I was
walking around McArthur getting accosted
by sex workers and you know drug dealers
while he was you know getting the ID but
it was crazy nonetheless and then you
know we've covered the immigration
situation in Miami we've covered the
homeless situation in LA all interesting
topics I can't say that we've really
risking our lives to tell a stories not
something that we want to do we love
telling stories we're both passionate
storytellers um but uh there are
journalists on current TV that are that
are way more courageous in that sense
I think we have yet to see mobile
technology really come into fruition in
the way that I think it eventually will
I think current will be heavily involved
in that when it does I also think that
current has a long way to go in terms of
mass penetration which you know for
better or worse all of our marketing up
until this point has been very
grassroots it's just people that stumble
upon the channel or see something about
us on the web tune in and then become
hooked and then they tell their friends
it's been very viral in that sense but
that said it doesn't have the mainstream
following that the hills has and I think
that is sort of a crime you know and you
know I think that in five years what I'd
like to see is just you know current
being a massive hit with people you know
all over the world tuning in to current
TV - to see perspectives that you're not
going to see anywhere else
you know we want to you know we really
want to enrich the dialogue between you
know young people and and you know the
concept of news and you know it's just
it's all about information dissemination
and I think that you know the more eyes
the more power you have and you know and
current definitely you know we want to
have that power we want to have that
influence and we want to use it for good